You are tearing me apart,
Lisa,
when you think of so bad,
it's good.
You probably think of some movie with
laughably horrible acting and writing a
movie that's so bad.
It becomes really fun to watch you watch
it and make fun of it with your friends
because such a bad movie takes itself so
seriously,
so bad.
It's good.
Movies go as far back as the b movies of
the forties and fifties the concept has
always been the same.
They're guilty pleasure movies where you
enjoyed the movie because of its
excessive use of movie tropes.
Pour over the top acting and terrible
camera work and it makes sense.
It's not hard to see the similar laugh
ability of robot monster in 1953 and
shark NATO.
The problem is analysis of so bad.
It's good.
Usually stops there,
but I think you can go much deeper than
that.
I want to talk about what's at the core
of this phenomenon and make the case
that the techniques of so bad,
it's good,
are present in tons of critically
acclaimed movies and almost all the time
it's done on purpose.
So let me explain
Michael.
Walk with me
so bad.
It's good.
Movies are an extreme version of the
idea that audiences enjoy theatrical and
over the top movies that's still take
themselves seriously.
This concept is called camp and it's
another tool at the disposal of a
filmmaker.
When you think of campy movies,
you may think they're always made
unintentionally,
like Tommy Wise Owl China film a serious
movie and accidentally creating the
ultimate camp classic.
But that's actually not the case.
Doctors constantly pretend to take their
dumb movie seriously to create a whole
new level of entertainment.
But if everybody is earnest and serious
and treating it like it's a,
you know,
a regular earthquake or it's you know,
an alien invasion,
whatever it is,
yeah.
Then then that sincerity kind of
translate it so then you can go even
further with your villain,
which is the shark.
Naomi do crazy stuff and that makes it
even more funny.
Yeah.
Camp isn't necessarily a genre of
movies.
Some movies can have elements of camp
without exclusively considering
themselves so bad.
It's good.
Maybe the perfect balance of camp and
sincerity is the princess bride.
The movie is actually smartly written
and well executed while also having a
ton of campy and corny moments is
similar.
This fellow,
I hate Tequila.
You seem decent fan.
I hate to die.
The source site blurs the line between
cartoonish and serious.
The stakes are high and the scene is
expertly choreographed,
but they also do random flips.
Campton makes the princess bride fun to
watch without making it a movie.
People make fun of.
It's over the top,
but never too much so,
and it always treats itself seriously.
Camp can actually sometimes save a
movie.
Johnny Depp's performance turns the
pirates of the Caribbean from a
derivative action flick to a charming
and hilarious franchise and it's because
of his can't be exaggerated but grounded
performance.
You want without doubt the worst pirate
type of
what you have heard of it.
Wes Anderson is a champion of camp.
His set pieces are famously symmetrical
to the point of impossibility.
The camera constantly spins from one
character to another.
He loves using outdated cartoonish,
special effects.
Any awkwardly cuts conversations at the
end of each sentence.
Why do you consider me your enemy?
Cause your girlfriend's stemming back.
Lefty scissors.
She's my wife now.
Congratulations.
Anderson creates charming and critically
acclaimed films.
Despite breaking countless film
conventions,
can't be film techniques,
give movies that extra flair that makes
them fun and devastating me.
Rewatch Hubble can't be filmmakers
strike the balance between the
impossible and the realistic so that
movies have elements of camp while also
having just a hint of seriousness so
they don't seem like they're trying too
hard.
Well,
for me,
the Reno Rafe is playing a real person
and making him a real person.
And um,
even though the context is this sort of
invented country in this invented
version of history and so on,
I sorta feel like we just try to make it
as realistic as it can be given,
given what it is.
Okay.
Saturated and campy filmmaking happens
all the time.
So this
becomes this,
this
becomes this
Quintin Tarantino loves camp.
If you have a villain,
make it a school girl and give her a
flail as a weapon.
His love for the theatrical and
exaggerated shows in the fact that in
all of his movies,
characters pretend to be somebody,
they're not.
Come on,
get care.
The result is hilariously over the top,
but serious moments of poor or flashy
acting.
I leave it there.
I leave it itchy and either that or we
ever,
Derek
camp is also extremely common in
dialogue.
So many movies have characters say
things nobody says in real life.
This is one doodle that can't be undid
ohms skillet,
but that doesn't make the dialogue bad.
Well,
sometimes it does.
I did not hit her.
It's not true.
It's bullshit.
I did not have her.
I did not.
Oh,
hi mark.
But it's also a way to make movies fun.
Aaron Sorkin is one of the best
screenwriters in cinema,
and he loves campy dialogue.
In many scenes,
he favors exaggerated dialogue over what
someone would actually say.
Yes,
sir.
Punch me in the face.
Go ahead,
Aaron.
Sorkin's famous walk and talk style from
West Wing feels extremely theatrical and
contrived.
It's been reused to the point that it's
been parodied in just about every TV
Sitcom.
He even parodies at himself.
Walk with me.
Amerisource Sorkin,
his snappy dialogue also gets reused to
an amazing degree,
which is you and me talking.
Dana,
I'm not other people.
I'm not other paper.
I'm not.
Other people don't talk to me like I'm
other people,
but it's not bad writing.
It actually takes a very talented writer
to create a style that's so easy to
parody,
but remains fascinating to watch.
He's not technically original,
but he still keeps it fresh.
We can feel his classic style,
but we don't load it.
We embrace it to a crazy amount.
Actually,
it's almost worshiped to the point where
they make actors recreates sorkin style
on talk shows.
Camp is letting movies,
b movies,
and it's a concept we feel everywhere.
Basically whenever a movie does
something over the top,
that would never happen in real life,
but the movie still executes it.
Sincerely.
Malaise and the room fits quite nicely
into these concepts of exaggerated and
entertaining filmmaking.
What makes the movie stand out is that
it's one of the few campy movies that
took itself completely seriously without
having any idea just how over the top it
was.
It's still camp,
but it's so unique because of how
blissfully unaware it is.
Hi doggy.
You're my favorite customer.
Thanks a lot.
Bye.
Brings me to the most important
component of camp camp defies binary
thinking in movies because it's both bad
and good.
It objectively breaks many of the
principles of filmmaking,
unrealistic acting,
cheesy dialogue and extreme filming
techniques are almost always frowned
upon,
but the crazy thing is camp is not bad.
Sometimes it's actually extremely
entertaining,
perhaps the most entertaining kind of
films that exist because many directors
can be serious and many directors can be
funny,
but not many can be so serious.
It's funny,
I embrace camp because movies shouldn't
always play it straight if they don't
want to.
On the contrary camp,
let's movies be what they were meant to
be entertaining,
so the next time you watch a movie,
don't just consider whether it's good or
bad.
Consider if you like it for it's guilty
pleasures.
Consider that it's so bad,
but that's not a bad thing.
It's actually a great thing.
It's so good that it's bad.
Do you want me to order a pizza or
whatever?
I don't care.
I already ordered a pizza.
You're thinking about everything.
Thanks for watching.
Slightly trends full.
Just a bit of a break from the norm,
just a little slot and the break,
the monotony of all that hard.